boy acne can really affect someone's
self-esteem I had acne really bad going
through junior high school and high
school and it really affected my
self-esteem so I would like to share
with you
something that I wish I knew back when I
had acne because it's so simple to get
rid of this if you understand the
mechanism and out of all the things that
can create acne there's one really big
vitamin deficiency that you need to know
about but I first want to give you the
kind of the mechanism first what is acne
well it's a situation where you have
multiple things going on at once
you have this gland this oil gland it's
called a sebaceous gland okay and it
makes oil and that oil is called sebum
and there's usually
a combination of an inflamed sebaceous
gland the gland is now enlarged and it's
also producing too much oil so you
usually have some oily skin and there's
usually also a bacteria involved which
is affecting the immune system and
creating more inflammation and that's
what makes up this redness that forms
the pimple and there's also sometimes
Associated like these blackheads or
whiteheads which are part of the tissue
part of this whole problem and typically
what is triggering acne is a shift in
hormones okay like puberty for example
you have this sudden Spike of androgens
and also when women have something
called PCOS polycystic ovarian syndrome
they also get acne as one of the
symptoms simply because there's a spike
in androgens now I have done a lot of
videos on acne before so I've talked
about different things that are involved
and one big thing that you should know
is is high levels of insulin because
usually you're eating too many carbs the
high carbs triggers the high insulin
which will then increase more androgens
so number one we have the high carb diet
but we also have something else that's
usually involved it's the frequency of
eating that also will trigger insulin
okay how many times you eat so that is
called snacking so the combination of a
lot of snacking and carbs are deadly for
acne and so if you want to get rid of
acne you're definitely going to have to
go low carb and you're also going to
have to do intermittent fasting so
you're going to just cut out the snacks
it'll make a big difference and it'll be
worth it and you won't be hungry if you
do this because you're now shifting to
burning fat Fuel and you're not
dependent on the next meal so you can go
for long periods of time without eating
and just the fact that you're fasting in
general creates a lot of benefits for
your skin youthful looking skin
anti-aging qualities not that you're
interested in that if you're a teenager
the vitamin that is involved in acne
it's a deficiency of this one vitamin
and that vitamin is vitamin D let's take
a look at how Vitamin D relates to this
first of all vitamin D regulates
that bacteria I mentioned that's
involved with acne it regulates it it
inhibits it and so when you're deficient
in this vitamin D
you're not going to have the control
over this microbe and so vitamin D is a
very potent
anti-bacterial when it relates to your
skin number two
when you take more vitamin D you'll have
less of that oil okay less of the Sedum
and the actual inflammation and swelling
and enlargement of that sebaceous gland
will now come down and start shrinking
the cells that make up the sebaceous
gland are also greatly influenced by
vitamin D3 and also when someone has
PCOS polycystic ovarian syndrome they're
usually always deficient in vitamin D
and so vitamin D is also involved in
helping you regulate androgens and then
some people might think that they get
enough vitamin D the great majority of
the public especially teenagers are
deficient in vitamin D it's almost
impossible to get vitamin D from your
diet okay you have to get it from the
Sun and many people just are not out in
the sun often enough
there's other things that block vitamin
D2 a high carb diet which gives you high
sugars will deplete your vitamin D as
well and this is why diabetics are
usually always deficient in vitamin D so
we have that we also have obesity is
another Factor the more fat you have on
your body the less vitamin D you're
going to have also if you have gut
issues you're going to be low in vitamin
D if your skin is darker you're going to
have a harder time converting the sun to
vitamin D and so there's many factors
that cause this vitamin D deficiency and
taking vitamin D in larger amounts can
be just the thing that you needed to
completely get rid of your acne so
number one I would recommend taking
roughly about 20 000 IUS of vitamin D3
every single day number two I would
highly recommend going on a low carb
diet the sugar that you eat or the
refined carbs that turn into sugar in
your bloodstream actually feed this
bacteria that involved in acne so we do
want to go low carb the third thing is
cutting out the snacks doing
intermittent fasting at least start out
with three meals a day no snacks just
make those meals bigger and then
eventually skip out breakfast and then
you have two meals that alone will
reduce your insulin greatly and then
your androgens will do better and that
might just handle your skin problem
right there and number four you want to
stop scrubbing your skin in this thought
that it might be just a dirty skin or
the pores are dirty so you have to scrub
it I used to do that crazy every morning
I'd be scrubbing cleaning my skin with
soap and using all sorts of medication
nothing actually worked in fact it
always made it worse because here I am
rubbing off all the good bacteria that's
supposed to defend against the bad
bacteria not to mention I'm irritating
all the inflammation and so you're doing
a lot of bad things to your skin if you
over sterilize it or or scrub it too
hard and then also you want to start
consuming foods that have some vitamin D
in them that would be cod liver oil
that's a really good one and the reason
I like cod liver oil is because it not
only has vitamin D but it also has
vitamin A another important vitamin in
acne this is why like Accutane which is
a synthetic version of vitamin A has
been used in the past for acne of course
it causes some slight minor
complications like increased risk for
suicide and liver failure but other than
that it's perfectly fine fatty fish like
salmon halibut would be really good to
get some good vitamin D now the question
is what food do you eat if you're no
longer going to eat carbs well for that
information I put this video up right
here check it out